صباح النور طبعا انا الان من مدينه ام قيس
او ما يعرف بجداره قديما هذه المدينه
التاريخيه الاثريه المدينه التي يعني تنعم
بالطبيعه الان المنظر من خلفي تطل على
بحيره طبريه وعلى هضبه الجولان وعلى نهر
اليرموك هذه المدينه تميزت بتعاقب الاثار
الاسلاميه واليونانيه والرومانيه عليها
وايضا اختيارها من افضل القرى عالميا على
قائمه السياحه يعني يعزز مكانتها على
خارطه السياحه العالميه
ويزيد من همم يعني همم
مدخول السياحي على اهل هذه المدينه على
همم يعني همم تقوم عليه هذه المدينه
ودائره الاثار من مشاريع الاستخدام
السياحه للتعرف عليها اكثر معي ضيفنا
الاستاذ زياد غنيمات مدير
اثار محافظه اربد اهلا وسهلا فيك استاذي
يعني نتعرف على مدينه جدارا او ام قيس كيف
تم اختيارها هذا ما سيعود على سكان
المجتمع المحلي
وماذا تتحدثون عن هذه المدينه الاثريه
والتاريخيه بدايه يعني ستتها نرحب بكم
اجمل ترحيب في مدينه ام قيس الاثريه صحيح
نشكر لاداره قناه العربيه هذه المبادره
الرائعه ولاول مره قناه يعني لها شهرتها
في العالم يعني تبث بث مباشر من مدينه ام
قيس الاثريه طبعا يجيء اختيار مدينه ام
قيس الاثريه او قريه ام قيس السياحيه من
افضل القرى السياحيه في العالم همم حسب ما
قررته منظمه السياحه العالميه هذا
الاختيار لم ياتي من عبث ماذا تم اختيارها
ماذا تقيمون هذه المدينه طبعا ام قيس يعني
بنحكي اول شيء تاريخ
واثاريا مدينه قياس تسلسلت فيها العصور
طبعا او الفترات الهلينستيه والفترات
الرومانيه والبيزنطيه والاسلاميه بشكل عام
ام قيس قد تكون من يعني من اجمل المدن
الاثريه الموجوده في الاردن لا بل في
العالم اجمع ام قيس مدينه طبعا همم تقوم
على حوالي 350 دونم فيها طبعا من الاثار
طبعا الشواهد الاثريه الظاهره على السطح
منها طبعا المدرجات المدرجين المدرج
الغربي والمدرج الشمالي وايضا فيها شارع
الاعمده والكنائس مدينه ام قيس كما اسرح
دائما لوسائل الاعلام كغيرها من المواقع
الاثريه فيها المعبد والكنيسه والمسجد
ايضا مدينه ام قيس ما يميزها انها مدينه
اثريه مدينه تراثيه مدينه طبيعيه اطلالته
على مثل ما تفضلته يعني
اطلالته على الحدود طبعا الاردنيه الحدود
الفلسطينيه وايضا الحدود السوريه على
بحيره طبريه على هضبه الجولان هذه طبعا
كانت من المقومات الكبيره اللي اهلت ام
قيس قريه ام قيس لان تكون من افضل القرى
السياحيه في العالم كلها كيف استقبل اهالي
مدينه ام قيس المجتمع المحلي هذا الخبر
خاصه وان يعني هناك من يتجهز لاستقبال
السياح طبعا هذا سيزيد من اعداد السياح
وزياره مدينه ام قيس يعني هل هناك مشاريع
لاستقدام السياحه اكثر للترويش لهذه
المدينه الجميله الاثريه الطبيعيه اكثر
نعم سؤال رائع جدا يعني امه قيس اصلا هي
من المدن الاثريه او من المواقع الاثريه
والسياحي اللي بتستخدم المجتمع المحلي
المجتمع المحلي له دور بارز في مدينه ام
قيس الاثريه حيث توجد استثمارات لابناء
المجتمع المحلي احنا بنحكي المشط ابناء
المجتمع المحلي من كانوا يسكنوا في
الاحواش او البيوت التراثيه الان الموجوده
في موقع ام قيس الاثري يعني همم على هذه
المدينه الاثريه يقام اللي هي همم حوالي
34 بيت تراثي والاهل ام قياس لهم مشاركه
رائع جدا في همم اقتصاديه قريه ام قيس
السياحي الاثريه شكرا شكرا استاذ استاذ
زياد يعني تحدثنا ربما الحديث يطول عن هذه
المدينه
الاثريه التي تعاقبت عليها الكثير من
الحضارات ويعني تتميز كما قال الاستاذ
زياد بالاعمده البيضاء والاعمده السوداء
يعني تتحدث الكثير عن هذه المدينه او هذه
القريه التي يعني سيئ امها الزوار من
مختلف يعني بلدان العالم للتعرف عليها
على هذه القائمه على كلامك انت من اول ما
بلشت اللايف وانت عم بتقولي ام قيس جداره
ومن شير للمشاهدين انه جداره سماها
الرومان لهذه المنطقه لانها كانت مدينه
مصوره لكثره الجدران فيها كانت مدينه
حصينه ومنعه وايضا تربطها خصبه فبالتالي
من الجدر فسميت بجداره ايضا ام قيس على
ايام العثمانيين بسبب كثره المكوكوس المكس
والجبايه والضرايه هذه هي سبب التسميات
واحنا فعلا سهى استمتعنا نعرف تفاصيل اكثر
عن ام قيس بانتظار ان نرى المزيد والمزيد